and so i think what the psychedelics and
ayahuasca do
is it's a
it's a sort of controlled therapeutic
psychosis
you're going to go in and you're
definitely going to be out of control
and we're going to walk you through you
the throwing up is part of it you know
everybody throws up and what's happening
is your mind is
deconfiguring
because it wasn't working the way it's
working
and i use the metaphor because i'm
trying to create
something called guaranteed to blow your
mind uh how ayahuasca works
and the idea is
if you think of our mind when we're born
is a rubric's cube and think of it being
in the wrapper and it's pristine
and then life messes it up
and we solve it so it looks like it's in
the wrapper
but as life gets complicated
the way it looks in the wrapper doesn't
work anymore
you know life on the outside is
different than life inside a womb
and if you keep trying to solve it for
how it is in the wrapper it's not
working anymore
and so i think what ayahuasca and
psychedelics do
is they scramble up that rubric's cube
but when they solve it it's a different
design than it was in the wrapper
and it's a design
that you can lean into
in your life
is this making any sense to you
i think so i've done quite a few
psychedelics
i'm not entirely sure how to think about
psychedelics like i almost think about
them as
connecting you to a spiritual level as
well absolutely
like yeah they're pretty they're pretty
wild and they can be extremely helpful
for
um
from trauma if you're
ready to kind of delve into it right if
you're if you're get if you get to the
head space where you're like okay
okay for instance when i was going
through that whole thing and in really
bad shape
after i figured diet out and then went
off of medications and then just waited
to get better
i didn't do
psychedelics for a number of years
because i was like i cannot
adding that into the mix right now like
that could go down a really
negative route
and yeah you don't want to have like i
mean some people have bad trips and then
they end up better afterwards like even
if it was a negative experience but at
that point i was like with especially
with ssri withdrawals like i can't risk
it it's too scary
um and it wasn't until i
was in a better space i would i actually
felt better i'm not saying this works
for everyone but i felt like stable
enough and i was like okay there's some
trauma really and there's some parts of
myself that i might be hiding that i
really need to sort out because you can
like manipulate yourself in all sorts of
ways and like hide little parts of
yourself
away so you don't see them and i was
like i want to make sure everything's
out in the open
and i did a number of pretty heavy dose
mushroom trips and it was incredibly
beneficial to me
i think
again i don't think there was any
negative downside
and i think i was able to sort through
some
problems that would have stayed hidden
for a long time
um psychedelics are really wild i think
that they they definitely need to be
used in a therapeutic setting
and people need to do more research so
as you remember
tell me if this fits your trip because
i've been trying to
explain it to people in a way so that
you there may be a way to do it without
the mushrooms
but
can
can you relate to this that you you took
them you were in a in a more of a mental
healthy
less fragile state than you'd been
before so you knew that and what
happened is
uh
in the middle of it your mind as you
know it
it's almost like it
it
uh decoupled the things that you
believed
uh that you you were adamant about you
weren't so adamant about but it was okay
and things just started being loose
uh and but you were somehow okay because
you were mentally healthy enough to not
go off the deep end and never come back
and what happens is
um
they they were they were loose but then
when they came back together again
here's the metaphor i remember
someone i know
came in
uh
and and she said this is what
psychedelics did for me
she said psychedelics work like a
plumber
and i said what do you mean
and she said
my mind is like plumbing
that works but it doesn't flow it's like
my mind is jammed together and i make it
through life but it doesn't flow and
psychedelics whip out the plumbing
and then the plumbing gets reassembled
organically
from a place that's more
organically cohesive inside
yourself and when you come out
the water flows
but before the trip uh if you haven't
had psychotic breaks and you weren't
thrown in hospitals
it's like your mind is plumbing but it
just it just doesn't work it creaks it's
and and maybe it was assembled because
of childhood trauma or who knows what or
disbelief and authority figures
but the psychedelics rips up the
plumbing
and then reassembles it in a natural way
and you can just exhale
and feel like life's going to be okay
without having to make sure that you
make it okay yeah okay i like that i
think i agree
i agree with most of that
i definitely agree with the feeling that
it gives you afterwards that you don't
have to control everything that things
are just gonna work out like it really
does
it really does leave you with a sense of
i don't have to control everything and
almost like god's will
but
psychedelics
so i i definitely had had that and then
for reorganizing
yeah i mean i've like i said i've had
really positive experiences with it like
for me i they made me at that time they
made me more loving
so i had more empathy towards other
people so there were people that i was
like this person is kind of annoying
right because there are people that are
like you don't get along with very well
like that person's kind of annoying or i
don't like that person that and it's not
like i was like actively mean but i had
one experience where i saw every
relationship in my entire life and how i
was contributing negatively to each of
those relationships
i was like
oh
i'm doing that like i'm contributing
negatively into the world that way
and it wasn't even judgmental like
that's the i was the interesting thing
it wasn't you're a bad person for doing
for acting that way it was
more kind it was like here's how you're
acting badly towards other people
um that's wrong
and then i was just like well i'll just
stop then
and so it was just like pretty simple it
was like i didn't know that i feel
really bad that i was contributing
negatively to some of these
relationships and i'll stop now and i'm
sorry and then it was
you know forgiveness and
they're they're just they're crazy